decoration of result of poll the
parliamentary election the London
borough of Wandsworth Battersea
constituency held on Thursday 8th of
June 2017 i James Madden being returning
officer for the Battersea constituency
here God hereby give notice that the
total number of votes given for each
candidate that the election is as
follows
Christopher Austin Francis Coughlin
commonly known as Chris Coughlin
independent 1234 Lois Elaine Davis Green
Party 866 Richard Adam Davis Liberal
Democrats 4401
Marsha Chantal de Cordoba Labour Party
25,000
[Applause]
twenty-five thousand two hundred and
ninety two Jane Elizabeth Ellison the
Conservative Party candidate twenty-two
thousand
[Applause]
Daniel Peter Lambert the Socialist Party
of Great Britain 32 and using power UK
Independence Party 357 and I do hereby
declare that Marsha shan't alter quarter
[Applause]
marsha Chantal to Cordoba is duly
elected to serve the CMV for Battersea
[Applause]
so firstly let me begin by thanking the
returning officer and all his love for
conducting the selection so efficiently
I'd also like to thank the police and
all supporters are for doing such a
fantastic job particularly in these
trying time I am extremely grateful to
the people of battery for electing me
this evening
as their representative I will be proud
to take my seat on the Lane benches and
have a common laborer is the party for
social justice in the UK our public
services have been under attack by the
Tory government that cares little about
the many and you have proven that they
only look after few they have tried to
privatize our NHS by the back door and
only Labour will stop it and undo those
horrific measure in magazine we have
been a huge amount of new housing but
are hardly any of these developments
have been affordable and hardly any have
been a little special home
[Applause]
developers have been able to advertise
to foreign investors and profits have
been placed before the needs of our
community I will work with the method
econ to tackle this practice other
schools have been under attack too
and within this borough of Wandsworth
there are plans funding has of up to 15
million if the toys do retain power some
of our schools in this borough will see
over a million pound flashed from their
budget labor not only Marvin but will
also have to fight to take that council
in 2018
got these vicious Cubs as a visually
impaired woman myself I feel
passionately about the rights of
disabled people accessibility in our
public places and on public transport
still fall short of what is reasonable I
will use my time in Parliament to lobby
for improvements in areas in the fifth
richest country in the world there can
be no excuses for leaving behind margin
a large number of our citizens
battersea voted 75% to remain and were
taken for granted I will not make the
same things
faculty needs a fighter and I will stand
up for people every day for local issues
for every single resident whether you
voted for me or not I will be there for
all for our my time in Parliament last
but by no means least I would like to
express my profound thanks to my team
but back aziz campaign was relevant i
budget but this dedicated group of
people gave up their valuable time and
achieve what looked like an impossible
goal at the beginning I owe a huge debt
in gratitude to all those activists from
other parts of the country who when they
recognized Massie was becoming a
marginal travel great distances to come
and help this was people power in action
so I will mention a few names because
you have all been amazing I did matteo
john mack mark ami James
q I'll also say a special fan my
brilliant agent mr. Tony Belton and
finally my amazing family who have just
been a true rock and the true support
and I will need you all over the next
five years
thank you
[Applause]